-Thank you for coming
back to the show.
It's nice to see you in person.
-It's very exciting.
Yes, you're back!
-You look good, buddy.
-You've been back for a while
but I'm back with you.
So now we can start.
-Now we are back.
-Now the show is back.
-I'm seeing you up
on the big screen.
-Oh.
-I saw you in "Doctor Strange."
-Yes.
-You had a --
[ Audience cheers ]
Right?
Yeah, you know what
I'm talking about.
We all saw that.
-But three people are like,
"spoiler alert."
Like, super bummed.
-Yeah.
Three people plug your ears.
But you're in it
for a little bit.
-How dare you.
It was a big moment for me.
-No, sorry.
-It was a big moment for me,
but that's fine, yeah.
Okay.
-But I mean -- but a little bit
of the magic from the movie
was from your scenes.
-That's right, yes.
No, I know, yes.
-But everyone freaked out.
You were Reed Richards
from Fantastic Four.
-Yes.
-Mr. Fantastic.
-I was.
-We all freaked out.
The audience I was in, everyone
was like, "Whaaat?"
-Thank you.
-"We love this!"
-I actually asked.
I called and I was like,
"Did they go, 'Whaaaa?'"
-Yes.
-And they said yes.
-We all did.
-Yes, they said yeah.
-Comic-Con, they just announced
all these new movies and they
announced that there's going to
be a Fantastic Four movie.
You're not allowed to say
anything.
-Nope.
-I'm not allowed to
really ask you.
-Right.
-But...
[ Laughter ]
You think?
-Do you think?
-Do you think? Could one think?
Could one think?
-Seriously, what have you heard?
I need to know.
[ Laughter ]
-They don't tell you anything?
-They don't tell you anything,
no.
-Until right before you're about
to do it.
-That's right.
-And there's also a rumor
that your wife,
Emily Blunt, will play
Sue Storm.
-Oh.
[ Audience ohs ]
You think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy, I'm going to tell you on
your show...
-Oh!
-It's --
-Oh, my gosh.
Someone killed him right now.
Could we get a medic?
That's acting right there.
-No, it's actually
a Marvel dart.
-There's a guy walking around.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I know you're a great actor,
but you're also a great writer
and director.
-Thank you.
-You've been busy, busy, busy.
-I got to come here more often.
This is boosting my personality.
-No, but you just finished
writing and I think you're about
to direct a movie called
"Imaginary Friends"?
-Yes, it's called "If," and it's
with Mr. Ryan Reynolds.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's an indie guy,
and this unbelievable actress
named Cailey Fleming.
If anybody watches
"The Walking Dead,"
she's on "Walking Dead," yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it's official.
Emily met her, saw her,
and was like,
"She's the best actress ever."So
that's it. It's done. It's over.
-That's it?
That is the best actress?
-That's it. We got best actress
on the planet.
-But you're reuniting with
Steve Carell.
-Yeah. I should have started
with this is
"The Office" reunion movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is "The Office"
reunion movie.
-Yes.
-Wow, no, it's not that at all.
-Nope, it's not, no.
-Well, what is "If"?
What is "Imaginary Friends?"
-"If" is basically a movie
about imaginary friends.
And yes, they are
these adorable, fun ideas
that kids have, but really, they
are also time capsules for all
of our ambitions, our dreams,
our hopes when we're kids.
So the movie is about what
if we could tap back into that?
-Ah, I love it.
I love the way you think, bud.
-Aw. Aww.
It's a horror movie.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it is not a horror --
It's a nice --
-It's terrifying.
-There was something that was
going around the Internet.
I just wanted to ask you
about this.
-The Internet is always right.
-Thank you.
It says, "'The Office' --
Is Jim really the villain?"
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, what, did you make
that up?
-No, I did not make it up.
We all decided --
-It's on a card.
-Yeah, I made the card.
I made the card,
but we all voted.
-What?
-93% agree with this.
[ Laughter ]
-Guys, we were doing so well.
-Did you manipulate Pam?
From the beginning?
-When you ask it like that,
it makes me uncomfortable.
-Yeah, it's true, I've never
done that before.
-"Did you manipulate Pam?"
[ Laughter ]
-[ Funny voice ]
Did you manipulate Pam?
[ Normal voice ]
I don't even know what voice
I was doing, I'm sorry.
-Can you imagine if that's what
it was?
-[ Funny voice ] What, my voice?
[ Laughter ]
John Krasinski, could you talk
about Pam?
[ Laughter ]
Please.
-Were you at Comic-Con?
-Please talk about Pam.
[ Laughter ]
We'd love it told.
-You're getting progressively
more British.
[ Laughter ]
-We want to know about Pam.
-The fear in your eyes
as the voice took over.
-[ Normal voice ] That's
the best acting I've ever done.
I don't know why --
Why would anyone do this?
Jim is one of the most loveable
characters
and funny characters
in the world.
This is so not true.
This is garbage.
-Well, they're on to me because
I played it as a supervillain.
[ Laughter ]
That's why I did "Fantastic
Four," to balance it out.
I had already done the villain.
-Let's talk about "Super-Pets."
This is a big deal.
You get to voice Superman.
-Yes.
-Is this one of those things,
the same as the Marvel thing,
they call up, who is it? Kevin?
-Kevin Feige's from Marvel,
yeah.
-He calls you up and he's like
[Deep voice] "Hey."
[ Laughter ]
John, how you doing, buddy?
Hey, it's me, Kevin Feige."
-Can you take a TV time-out?
We got to talk about this.
-"It's Kevin Feige.
It's Kevin Feige."
-Oh, no, now it's Will Arnett.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, it's Will.
-Hey, man.
-Hey, man. Hey, man. Hey, man.
You want to do it?
-Hey, man, do you want to be
Mr. Fantastic?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, man.
-Yeah.
-You don't? Oh, you don't?
Oh, you don't want to be
Mr. Fantastic?
Oh, you don't? Oh, really?
-Sean will do it.
-Oh, you want to be Superman?
Yeah, you should go to DC.
Go do DC.
-Do DC.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-None of that is useable.
-[ Normal voice ]
We have to air it.
-If only for Will.
-We have to air it
just for Will.
But then you get to do this.
Dude, you get to play Superman.
It's unbelievable.
And this is like a great movie
the whole family will love.
It's you, Kevin Hart,
Dwayne Johnson.
-Yes.
-The cast is insane.
It's super funny.
But you get to play Superman,
and then kind of your pets
have to save the world.
-Yes, which, at first, I was
really excited to play Superman
until they made my dog
bigger than me
and somehow more handsome?
It's played by Dwayne "The Rock"
Johnson, by the way,
who called and was like,
"Hey, will you do 'Super-Pets'?
Make the dog cooler. Oh, it's
a yes? Okay, great. Perfect."
-And have you taken
your daughters to see this?
-They loved it. It was --
They were laughing
very, very hard.
I think up until now
they didn't believe
I actually was in the business.
'Cause they've never seen
anything I've done.
So it's like, "Quiet Place,"
not yet.
"Jack Ryan," things like that,
nope.
-And this is the perfect movie
to take them to see.
-They were like, "Wow, you're
not an accountant."
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's John Krasinski
as Superman in "DC League of
Super-Pets."
Take a look at this.
-From Metropolis, I'm Lois Lane.
-Hey, Lois!
I know you like these, so I got
you one from actual Paris.
I don't know why I said it
like that.
-And I got you one of these
from 43rd Street,
which is like a full
three blocks out of my way.
-During rush hour?
Wow, that's like me
flying to Mars.
-What, you can fly?
I always thought the cape was
just a cute accessory.
-Oh, so you think I'm cute?
-I said the cape was cute.
-[ Sighs ]
You think I'm cute.
-Are we licking faces right now?
Because if we're licking faces,
I got to get in on --
[ Barking ]
-Yeah, come on.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-John Krasinski, everybody!
"DC League of Super-Pets" hits
theaters Friday.
We'll be right back with
Rege-Jean Page. Stick around.